all Mexicans are rapists the Muslim ban
he said there were fine people on both
sides he supported white supremacists
either Spike Lee you're too stupid to be
representative of this movement and this
project or you are lying in order to
leverage this to don't vote for Donald
Trump
there is no third option all right Spike
Lee this has been there was an interview
one it sort of set up this clip first
there's a little bit of context that
needs to be understood I really want to
know do you genuinely think that Donald
Trump could be a racer do you think
racism has been on the rise since Donald
Trump I don't buy it I've talked about
that but it seems like now the rhetoric
is heating up even more oh yeah we're
they're trying to paint him as a racist
so the 16:19 project is it's a project
from the New York Times okay and it's
designed right a series of pieces
showing that everything basically the
basis of America is the it's result of
slavery genocide all of it everything
bad and they've got a number of
high-profile celebrities from Spike Lee
to Oprah trying to promote it now some
leaked internal discussions actually
show the decision was made to shift the
narrative away from the failed Russia
story let's erase it
after Muller failed to find any
collusion the editor in chief New York
Times supposedly at a loss how to cover
Trump so we decided all right let's
let's let's just paint all of America's
history is racist and say it's more
racist now than ever it's more racist
now than slavery because Trump couldn't
possibly be honest right I don't know so
it's not really about slavery I want to
be clear about this that's how they're
trying to sort of frame this they just
need something to make President Trump
look that by their own admission right
and they're asking this question like
why are we even asking anymore if he's a
white supremacist they're they're just
saying it they're not trying to paint
him as a racist they're saying she is
right well that's what they're do you've
been marginalized more I have been my
white part has been more marginalize yes
I mean there's no question that slavery
is a part of our art history as a
country whether whether it defines the
nation and to say that is to say that
every person who is a part of it
know what did you fight in the as part
of the Union Army you know you must have
also been part of slavery as well right
I mean there's no nuance to it other
than just to say hey I don't want you to
forget every one of you is a piece of
[ __ ] tagline 1619
right for my everything you enjoy to
taste like spot you still can't ride the
Amtrak yeah but it makes the assumption
that the United States would not have
been a great country without slavery so
we had all the natural resources we had
great navigable rivers which turns out
to be very important and we had a great
system of government that was growing
what we did a whole segment on this if
people go back through the archives
where actually the South was was
hindered by slavery if you look at the
economic developments that happened in
the north it didn't happen in the South
because slave labor doesn't tend to put
in they're not burning the candle at
both ends and they're not necessarily
doing an honest job and I'm not saying
that slaves were dishonest I'm saying
they should have done an honest job of
famously
they should have sabotage and a lot of
them did but if you look at the
developments they were hampered by
slavery all right so this is just I just
want to make sure that we set this up so
you understand why Spike Lee is making
the rounds and is it on Anderson
Cooper's 360 to plug this 16 19 project
you'll be hearing a lot about it let's
start this off this is important it's
very important to me uh because so much
we're not taught this in school right
you know we're still dealing with
Christopher Columbus and all the other
stuff Christopher Columbus not real or
he didn't land on Plymouth Rock III
don't wait wait so there was American
slavery in 1492 that's what works it's
how you teaching one thing and then the
next thing and then the next
I think the Indians were enslaving other
it was linear Wow tell me more is it my
meds well is that good thing is he's
going to be telling you a lot more
question number two today who did not
learn about slavery in school I think a
lot of people aren't taught that we are
uniquely responsible for ending slavery
yeah you know their place in the modern
world but let's go to the next clip this
country United States America was a
built upon the genocide of native people
and and slavery I mean that's a fact
well you can see that no one is wants to
minimize here the atrocities that were
committed against Native Americans back
then we called them Indians and as
Elizabeth Warren says Redskins but she's
1000 1/64 so it's okay yeah she can say
that Nate
one thing people to understand they were
mostly white we've talked about the so
many times I'm sorry to repeat it they
were wiped out through diseases that the
settlers brought inadvertently because
these people had not developed an
immunity out of it I think 250,000
natives Columbus's first stop right in
one of the Americas Hispaniola I should
do the Bryan Callen that lady new
diseases wiped out over 230,000 of the
indigenous we've learned 1517 that's
nearly 95 percent of their population a
big part of that by the way they hadn't
domesticated the horse right this idea
if you're coming into contact with a
domesticated horse for the first time
this whole idea of bow and arrow
horseback culture it's a lie having
domesticated the horse and they didn't
use the wheel yeah and by the way when
we come and like accidentally killed 95%
of you just by shaking your hand it's
our bad sorry it's like this is the part
where again we've talked about this
before where there's there's just a lack
of nuance when you go to the 16:19
project and all you want to focus on is
one part of history that involves
slavery to use that to push a political
agenda today right yeah then then you've
ignored the fact that sure was slavery
part of our history did slavery you know
set certain things in motion in this
country and and somewhat our youth still
has some reverberating effects to this
point I think we don't we just disagree
on how much effect is so fastly and what
needs to be dealt with it well I'm
saying with the Native American
population I mean there there there's
unquestionably atrocities occurred yeah
but to say it's only atrocities what I
have a problem with is the term genocide
okay this is a problem because there are
more people with Elizabeth Warren is a
perfect example more people with a
percentage of Native American than ever
and that's because most of it was due to
interbreeding we didn't want to kill all
of them no we wanted to marry them we
wanted to have population but yeah look
look through the most bloody battles
right then this certainly did happen
Wounded Knee you probably know about
because you learned about it in school
we're not taught 150 or 350 Native
Americans killed or wounded
they're also 25 American soldiers killed
39 wounded listen it's a little
different from a genocide because if
you're talking about the Holocaust like
well you know what the Jews got their
licks into that what a genocide yeah
well you know they've got six million
but it's a battle those Jews they pulled
off a couple of million you know there
was a give-and-take know that's what
genocide is a complete extermination by
the way sometimes massacres went the
other way 16:22 deposit
I doubt hot engines they had no
casualties in this battle they slaughter
347 English settlers yeah it's not the
way genocide you look and don't forget
this is something people don't remember
we don't teach this in history Native
American tribes were warring with each
other before we got lots and lots they
were incredibly violent to go south how
do you think Cortez defeated yet 500
conquistadors no he listed the help of
other native tribes we toss them some
firewater and said listen these guys
have been enslaved in you to collect
their gold for centuries how about you
try the guys with the metal hats well
and when we show up and we have kind of
peaceful relationships with some tribes
and then we start to move you guys were
already worrying what you're really
doing is basically saying we're really
pissed off that when you came in you
were better at war than we were yeah
right we were already trying to take
each other's land and and I was
succeeding and now you kicked my butt
and I'm really pissed about that sorry
not sorry sorry I mean here's what I
will have to say is that if you if you
jump in and you ask the question of did
we have a right to come in and take this
land I don't I don't necessarily know
that there is any particular more or
less right between the people who are
ready here is it at first mover's right
I mean that's the part where basically
where the narrative falls apart when you
hear people say well these these were
the indigenous people okay so so well we
don't care about the indigenous species
that were here before those indigenous
people came here are they important oh
well yes sure they are more important
and then you're just saying okay great
well this is what she's given of all
people yeah every single person should
leave this context right it just it
falls apart understand will be made at
some point so let's say we never did
back then today a helicopter or a plane
goes already guess what now it's been
made there's going to have to be a clash
of civilizations when there's a more
advanced civilization yeah they meet
either they adapt right either they
become a part of this music or they get
what that's what that's what has
happened always we're in a unique time
in history in that we don't go take over
countries that are in the air like
Canada we don't do that because we've
advanced beyond it but this is right it
worked throughout the globe for all time
yeah yeah atrocities but the idea that
America is uniquely responsible for it
that's the problem I have but again drew
this is all a thin veil to get to the
real reason which is the 1619 product is
Donald Trump a white supremacist
why are we still asking is this guy a
white supremacist I mean like do you
that is that it's not even acquaintance
anymore oh he's just said okay I mean
the Muslim rapist mercy drug dealers I
mean it is the wouldn't that guy before
going to hear some Cooper do his life
he's like not listen I need my heroin
and Damon their glasses because most
people aren't your own question by the
way and then he talks about how can you
have so many inaccuracies in one
sentence it's the Muslim ban all
Mexicans are racist okay let's just go
through this and I can talk about the
good people on both sides listen there
was no Muslim ban there was never a
Muslim ban all Muslims were never banned
in the United States what you're talking
about is an immigration ban on seven
countries that were identified as
countries of concern from Barack Obama
and they were put on a temporary ban six
months with the rest there's never been
a Muslim ban stop it okay all and this
is this is what bothers me I mean you
know this is a lawyer they teach us to
politicians to them like obviously he's
being disingenuous a little bit here but
he could have at least just sort of
curbed his language by just saying you
know he said that Mexicans are rapists
instead he said saying all Mexicans are
rapists you're just making it too easy
sweetheart I know all Mexicans are
rapists really did he say that's the
first thing to tell a politician is
don't use words like all right
absolutely here completely totally and
that's why when we do it on this show we
only do it by design if we're 100
percent certain like making sure that
half-asian Bill Richmond gets me
unblocked from Rashida boobs there's you
know all Mexicans are rapists Donald
Trump was talking about ms-13
people who rape and kill women and shoot
that's what they do it's crazy that's
their calling card they're the killing
women and children bandits by the way
did you see Anderson Cooper push back on
that I did we no no we didn't have that
well yeah and then we know we have it
next yes so this is the next one we're
not now he goes on to the one that they
paired a lot that Donald Trump his
justification along with all Mexicans
are rapists and the Muslim man is that
he praised neo-nazis do your Spike Lee
tell me he can't make it a decision
between what's right and wrong
what's love and hate there's both people
I mean that's kind of behind this I mean
that that quote it's asking me attached
to him he's on he's gonna wrong side of
history and that's the first thing thing
in the state that quote it's interesting
cuz there's a lot there's now a movement
among some Republicans to kind of
rewrite the history of what the
president said what no rewrite history
yes we are attempting to rewrite history
by simply showing a clip of Donald Trump
condemning neo-nazis in his own words
and you had people and I'm not talking
about the neo-nazis and the white
nationalist because they should be
condemned
totally but you had many people in that
group other than neo-nazis and white
nationalists revisionist huh oh it's
like you know all those times when I
hear on CNN that McDonald has never
called out neo-nazis or white
supremacist you know I can't look at the
amazing made-up videos that people are
able to create in the Korean industry I
mean he's the same amount of times in
one phrase as Spike Lee was wrong yeah
yes here's the thing so Anderson Cooper
didn't push back on the Mexicans comment
he's a journalist I thought I thought he
was trying to get to the truth or push
back on that and then carried his water
on this comment and said yeah they're
trying to rewrite history right spike
right I'm cool right yeah I like your
glasses you probably tried to lift him
he will be my son wink did he the way
there was a way it was a week between
guys with glasses G Morgan Jr was there
too I don't know what's so I forgot
hit the notification bell if you
subscribe because the patricians don't
mean a whole lot subscribe on iTunes
leave us a rating and most importantly
do join mug Club lot of credit calm
slash mug Club not only do you get the
full day leash like hours and hours of
con
we can never air on YouTube but my
half-asian water-filled Richmond is very
expensive so when we're doing our legal
stuff with big tech or even
representatives like Rasheeda too late
just understand mug club supports that
especially since we've been D monitors
yes yeah and that's a show you don't
just one thing to that point is if
people only really see like the tip of
the iceberg of all the things that we
have to fight with on the banks I mean
it's a constant it's a constant battle
so mug Club is what allows us to
continue I mean how many tens of
thousands just in basic paperwork last
year are people making false claims I
mean there were well between people
stealing content between people accusing
us of stealing content just this week
there was 14 yeah Wow um you know just
having to deal with that I mean it's
it's ID we're keeping you busy buddy a
big part of before the show with bill
Richman having built us coming down no
no it's only gonna make me mad you're
being sued by an angry [ __ ] who thinks
that you're guilty of hate speech and
claims the socialism shirt is actually
her face yeah I know it's not true but
it might just be worth it to pay this
crazy person to go away am i right
mug clubbers made it happen all right
let's go out to the let's go to the
Thank You mug Club otherwise we would
just be we would be crossing the finish
line like in the movie stunt was it
small soldiers with the gore goals or
whatever it was like and the guys trying
to walk and they're all jumping on that
would be us just with just hundreds of
angry [ __ ] and Vox employees trying
to do this show if I'm not happy I'm
bill Richman looking over our shoulder
next clip talking now we go directly to
the KKK with Dame Edna Spike Lee they're
not even hiding is you know at least
they're with the KKK people too -
cowards - my house game the the the dog
was it like come on out so our guys in
the white house oh well good I don't
think that's how a dog whistle works
isn't like it's a silent whistle only
laughter in here I know he thinks
they're handing the whistles very Papa
is telling the KKK to go for it as you
say any example any examples of
whistles you know what any actual any
pictures of Donald Trump even with an
actual whistle I think what we should
know is remember from the clip with
Trump where he was condemning the
neo-nazis in the white houses and then
it wasn't just enough to do it once but
he did it again and so after doing it
twice I definitely got the bird read
between the lines is I love yo Nazis
about Nationals right that was what I
mean that's what I got hey hey I had my
fingers crossed and 360 more like 160
epic it's going over yeah all of these
examples can be easily debunked quick
Google search or a clip just as quickly
as a 77 cents on the dollar pay gap myth
so if it's so obvious why is this even a
question anymore
oh because you've brought no evidence
how about you show me a clip look at
even just one picture one picture any
one one picture of Donald Trump with a
loud whistle I'll allow that and
apologize we have another clip I think
they get two more spots it's in the
dossier let's go what do you hope people
are kind of reflecting on in terms of
the impact of you know enslaved people
the generations right back it's about
here 69 um whose names will never know
why are these people getting behind this
guy digging me the wrong side history
with him the 16:19 project why he's
there this is probably teaches people
naked because we wasn't taught it in
school and instead us don't vote for
Trump can area where someone is there to
specifically plug yeah a particular
project tell us about your new film
pineapple Express - I have a Swartz yeah
nothing to do with the top you know I do
appreciate about it though is it's
honest because they could have continued
to say no no no this is just an
educational project here we are
educating and it would have been a
little bit more you know circumstantial
to be able to say oh you know this is
actually an attack on trying to change
voting minds away from the president
because of the upcoming election and
coincidentally just at the timing of
everything we couldn't have done it any
other time between now and 1619 but this
was the year we were going to do it yeah
at this very moment in history it was a
calm but but that is the part that I
appreciate is that the glasses the for
centuries yeah wait and then bring out
the guy who did do the right thing right
maybe that's the part where you go you
go yeah thank you I appreciate you
letting us know that this is just
everything that we believe the left to
be they kind of veiled for a long time
you know kind of like okay you know a
little bit of sleight of hand now
they're just doing out in the open
yeah and I think there is a silver
lining there because now people like for
the longest time really up until Donald
Trump people thought CNN was legitimate
news yeah yeah and I have been I've been
shouting this from the rooftop like the
RICO law guy where I was saying like no
listen it's not a missing your problem
is CNN because they presented as though
it's actually unbiased and now we know
through these interactions with people
like Spike Lee Anderson Cooper and you
you good yeah exactly so by these
standards we'd actually have to say that
President Barack Obama was also a racist
right against Bible right okay so he
just hear me out for a second I don't
know if I want to you got to give me
just a sec they're legal liability here
yeah just follow me right so if I had a
son he would look like Trayvon Martin
right and then we had hands up don't
shoot and we had all right we're gonna
send
we're gonna send AG down there to take a
look at this we're gonna go through all
this stuff and so black lives matter
comes out of this movement right so you
have this huge this massive overreach of
black lives matter trying to make people
think that the that we every white
person in America doesn't think that
your life matters especially police
officers even though it was a black
police officers involved in some of
these incidents right right and so
there's this massive overreach what
happens typically when there's a massive
overreach by one side in one of these
things right so you have people on this
side
there's the big push by people on the
other side I think I would make the
argument that Donald Trump is not what
has brought white supremacists kind of
out into the open it's a huge overreach
by black lives matter that is allowed
that I'm not saying it's the sole cause
now I'm saying it has allowed that to
happen because all of a sudden all these
guys who are kind of hiding in the
shadows are like what the hell's going
on over here these guys are out
overreaching and now publicly certainly
did not condemn black lives matter
no as emphatically as Donald Trump has
condemned neo now exactly what you never
did that so by these same standards
Barack Obama by the way you know news
flash it's possible to be racist and be
black yes okay I'm not saying he was I'm
saying that if we use these same
standards we have to look at hit on the
same lens you're looking at Trump he
would be looked at as potentially being
a racist idea though that you can not
maybe black people can be discriminatory
but they can't be racist because they're
not in a position of the systemic powers
that be a presidential office is I don't
want this to be a message where because
Spike Lee and some of the folks who are
at the top of the 16:19 project that it
that there's a denial of slavery and its
impact on those people or even people
that know in the generations afterwards
of course now some impact it and this is
the important part is that if you're out
there trying to think about how to
intelligently talk to someone either
who's confused about what it is or
someone on the other side that's trying
to say oh you know this is what the
project is don't don't bury your head go
look at the project just take it with a
grain of salt just recognize when
there's facts right history versus
political message okay if you want to
talk about what today is and how
different it is and how we've come as a
country and what we are today versus in
1619 you got to know the facts so the
problem unfortunately is is it's
obviously the incredible bias like Spike
Lee is sort of the spearhead or at least
seen that we have the modern black
rights movement well that isn't I don't
whatever rights are they fighting for
now I'm not talking about discrimination
I'm talking about individual races what
rights are they fighting for now when
they talk about black rights movement
when they talk about white public I
don't know
genuine this could just be me being tone
deaf it could be a blind spot I don't
know I have a car that it does have some
blind spots yeah Korean so no it's a
Korean car blind son
I wouldn't do that in front of my
half-asian we're but let's look at these
Chinese yeah can you tell the dude it's
like if you season when you say he's
Korean Chinese anyways everyone's white
black Klansmen Malcolm X do the right
thing yeah there's there's a reason he's
on the show right there's a reason he's
been chosen as a spokesperson for 16:19
it's because he's seen as a figurehead
right so they've clearly presented as an
authoritative figure on this topic and
he is either demonstrable
completely misinformed or he's
deliberately misinforming everybody else
there are only two options all Mexicans
are rapists the Muslim ban he said there
were fine people on both sides he
supported white supremacists either
Spike Lee you're too stupid to be
representative of this movement and this
project or you are lying in order to
leverage this - don't vote for Donald
Trump there is no third option and I
think a part of this is these people
being misinformed is um it's idiot
bubbles like Spike Lee goes out and says
oh he said all Mexicans are rapists yeah
he said he said that that he likes white
supremacists he said he didn't like my
glasses it was Tom Tom Hanks said World
War two I remember at one point was
based on racism and fear mongering
they're surrounded by people in this
entertainment industry and by the way
that includes the media okay
where no one just says huh
exactly what there's no checks the Spike
Lee wouldn't go out and spout this if
Anderson Cooper before he went on it
like any time we talked about this
before they only go through a show map
and one of us has a point that we're not
quite people I don't think it's the
strongest point yeah Anderson Cooper
could have at least done Spike Lee a
favor and we all Mexicans are rapists
Amos Lee Cooper - you didn't say all
just real quick hey you know we should
stick to facts here right by the way
Warby Parker I don't know spicy we
didn't think it going - Bryan Callen is
gonna be on the show Spike Lee and the
people at the New York Times there let
me simplify this for you
they are either misinformed or they are
miss informing period neither option is
a good look for a legitimate news outlet
hey there youtube viewer subscribe to
the channel hit the notification bell if
you're already subscribed to this
channel because that lets you know when
new videos come out and they don't show
up on the youtube search feed also there
are videos plan
in boxes here click one of those just of
all the things that I just mentioned all
you have to do is one and if you don't I
will run for the United States
presidency under the one one thousand
sixty four percent Cherokee Party I have
yet to pick my VP